haremos este vídeo con una división de
dos dígitos tenemos nueve mil 815
dividido entre 65 y aquí los invito a
que ustedes pasen el vídeo y puedan
hacer esto por ustedes solos
asumiendo que pasaron del vídeo y lo
intentaron vamos a trabajarlos juntos
vamos a reorganizar esto de tal manera
que sea mucho más sencillo trabajarlo
tendremos nueve mil 815
que será dividido entre
65 tenemos entonces esta información
aquí es donde se vuelve un poco
complicado cuando tenemos dos dígitos y
más que complicado se vuelve como un
arte ir y abrirte les voy a ir
explicando poco a poco si nosotros
tenemos por ejemplo nueve mil 815 entre
sesenta y cinco la manera en la que
podemos pensar es cuántas veces cabe el
65 en este primer dígito en el 9 pues
realmente no cabe ninguna vez así es que
nos estiraremos hasta el siguiente
dígito tenemos entonces cuántas veces
cabe 65 en 98 y eso ya tiene mayor
sentido el 65 en el 98 que habrá una
sola vez sin pasarse
así es que multiplicaremos 1 por 65 será
igual a 65
y podemos hacer la resta donde a 98 le
restamos 65 85 es igual a 39 menos seis
es igual a 3 y con esto podemos
confirmar que vamos bien ya que el
residuo será mucho menor que este 65
vamos más adelante y entonces podremos
bajar el siguiente número que será este
1 bajando tendremos entonces que
bajaremos este siguiente dígito y ahora
tendremos 331 entre 65 aquí es donde
viene el arte también vamos a dividir
cuántas veces cabe 65 en el 3 bueno no
caben ni una sola vez 65 en el 33
tampoco así es que tomaremos la cifra
completa
cuántas veces cabe 65 en 331 y una
manera en la que a mí me funciona y se
las pongo en la mesa por si ustedes
gustan ocupar la será que si yo pienso
que el 65 se parece al 70
lo estoy redondeando hacia algún número
mayor y 331 lo redondea 300
si yo pienso cuántas veces cabe el 70 en
el 300 pues puedo pensarlo como cuántas
veces cabe el 7 en el 30 y lo pensaremos
como 44 por 70 será 280 y si hago la
resta me quedarán 20 pensando en que
estos números son redondeados y
aproximados a estos consideraré usar
entonces el 4 dado que suena bastante
inteligente aquí 4 por 5 es igual a 20
llevo 24 por 6 es igual a 24 y 2 que
llevo 25 26
si hago la resta tendré 331 menos 260
será 10 136 esto lo tomaremos como 13
entonces ya que es más pequeño este 13
menos 6 es igual a 7 y este se vuelve un
22 menos 2 es igual a
y aquí es donde viene lo interesante
este 4 no nos está funcionando porque
porque nuestro residuo es más grande que
el 65 que estamos utilizando aquí 71 es
más grande que 75 por lo que podemos
decir que
podemos dividirlo entonces en 35 nuestro
siguiente dígito no era 4 será 5 5 por 5
25 llevamos 25 por 6 32 que llevamos 32
y ahora si ya tiene sentido esto me
refería cuando les decía que no nos
pasáramos tenemos 331 menos 325 15 será
igual a 6 éste se convierte en 303 menos
30 ahora si este 5 será el número
adecuado ya que nuestro residuo es mucho
menor que 65 y podremos bajar el
siguiente dígito
tendremos 65 entre 65 bueno esto está
facilísimo 65 entre 65 será igual a 1
165 65 65 60 y 50 y en este caso hemos
terminado nuestra división ya que el
residuo queda igual a 0 y no tenemos
puntos decimales más adelante
así es que nuestra respuesta correcta
será 9.815 entre 65 será igual a ciento
voy a ocupar los mismos colores 150 y
y de esta manera ya saben cómo hacer
divisiones con dos dígitos nos vemos en
otro vídeo